so there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia : unusual
articles I just remembered as that
Wikipedia list it's a collection of
hundreds of articles about unusual
unexpected and unbelievable subjects no
matter what link you click it's bound to
be interesting for that reason every
week I'm going to click on a new link
and teach you a little bit more about
our amazing world with that let's find
this week's article oh you know what I
know what this is we're going to do this
so believe it or not there's still land
on earth that's not part of any country
Berta Wheel is that land this 800 square
mile area between Egypt and Sudan is
claimed by neither Egypt nor Sudan to
understand why this is we have to go
back to 1899 at the turn of the 20th
century Britain had a large and rapidly
expanding empire across the world a
large part of this Empire was in Africa
where colonialism had taken root Britain
held a complex level authority in
Northeast Africa
and through that they got to decide that
the border between Sudan and Egypt was
going to be the 22nd parallel the
problem with this border was that it
made no consideration for the placement
of actual people it just put a big line
in the sand and arbitrarily split up
tribes and people in 1902 Britain
decided to draw a new administrative
boundary that put into consideration the
use of land by various tribes that way
tribes wouldn't be living in one
territory and grazing their cattle in
another fast forward 114 years in both
territories are now fully fledged
countries no longer under British rule
the problem is Sudan now recognizes the
1902 administrative boundary as the real
border while Egypt recognizes the 1899
border on the 22nd parallel as the real
border what this means is that BIR Tawil
is south of egypt's border so Egypt
thinks it's part of Sudan while also
north of Sudan's border so Sudan thinks
it's part of Egypt this doesn't really
create many problems though since
there's a whopping zero people living in
berto eel there's not even any roads or
anything it's just 800 square miles of
nothing ruled by nobody
this same border issue does create
issues in other places though the Hawaii
triangle is 10 times bigger than bir
tawil
and instead of being claimed by no
country it's claimed by two countries
that's because it's north of what egypt
thinks is the border while
simultaneously south of what sudan
thinks is the border the two countries
actually care about this piece of land
because there are things there's a road
and sea access and 1,000 residents
currently the land is administered by
Egypt but let's get back to Berto wheel
in his 2014 book Alistair Bonett said
that Berto wheel is the only place on
the planet that is both habitable and
unclaimed the biggest unclaimed piece of
land is the Mary Byrd land but that's
not considered to be habitable land
since you know article there's one other
area of technically unclaimed land on
the Danube River between Croatia and
Serbia due to a similar border dispute
however practically the land while on a
map in a part of either country is well
divided administrative Lea therefore
Bert oil is the only place on earth
where people might actually be able to
create a new country so what's stopping
people well not much scores that people
have claimed the land as their own
country but if my video on how to create
a country taught you anything it's that
it doesn't matter if you think you're a
country it matters if other people think
you're a country no recognized country
currently recognizes any claim to BIR
Tawil likely because nobody has set up a
government or permanent population in
Beart oil while the land is habitable
there's no infrastructure to bring in
supplies to support a settlement with it
being a desert and all agriculture
doesn't do so well so any prospective
country founder would need to build a
road or Airport to bring in food in
addition there really aren't any natural
resources so it's unlikely that any
country established in the area would be
self-sustaining economically however if
someone was able to set up a democratic
government in the area with a permanent
population it's entirely possible that
they would gain recognition and there
would be a 197th country in the world or
194th or 193rd or
really just depends on who you ask
you